everybody remembered where they were
what they had been doing when the SCP
Foundation revealed themselves to the
world it was an event that had so
fundamentally changed the lives of every
person on Earth that it became pretty
hard to forget that momentous horrible
day even though for most people it had
begun as a day like most others Dane
Moss had been at home when it started
his roommates were talking about buying
an air hockey table for their place
something to liven up their Saturday
nights even as he half listened to them
discussing it Dane figured it would
never happen he was right of course but
he never could have anticipated the
thing that stopped it all of them had
stopped and Fallen silent as the news
report came through a group calling
themselves the SCP Foundation previously
responsible for the containment of
anomalous objects entities and phenomena
had declared its new intention to
exterminate the entire human race Dane
Split Second believed that the broadcast
was a Cloverfield style viral marketing
stunt for a new movie was quickly
disproved when the ground started to
shake unbeknownst to him the foundation
was not only real but a detonated
nuclear charges along the back of
scp-169 an enormous ancient arthropod
thats body had made up an archipelago
adrift in the ocean the detonation
caused the Leviathan to stir resulting
in massive earthquakes and tsunamis Dane
was the only one to make it out of the
apartment alive elsewhere Joe Reese had
been grabbing a coffee on his way home
from work he briefly overheard the news
report but barely paid it to any mind
then waiting for his flat white
wondering what the holdup was he caught
a part of a conversation between two
people behind him what is that thing one
asked I don't know but its face is pure
nightmare fuel the other replied a bunch
of pictures of it just appeared on
everyone's socials it's really freaky
stuff a sudden shriek went out from a
number of the coffee shop patrons Joe
noticed a towering humanoid Shadow being
cast by something behind him its arms
were stretched out disproportionately
long and it was attacking the two people
behind him acting on an instantaneous
fight-or-flight response Joe ran without
looking back to
cscp-096 slaughtering everyone that had
seen its face around the same time as
the foundation's ominous announcement
was played over every news channel on
the planet Renee Hudson and Sky Soto had
been on a date the pair of them had been
enjoying hanging out playing a few
mildly competitive games at the bowling
alley but there was still something
unspoken lingering in the air neither
sky nor Renee really felt any connection
they liked each other's company but that
was as far as it went although neither
one of them knew how to broach the
subject for fear of hurting the other's
feelings and in the same vein neither of
them could have predicted the commotion
that would happen next the noise came
from outside the deafening screams
followed by a flood of people running
for their lives hundreds if not
thousands were fleeing any that fell
over in the street being trampled
underfoot by everyone behind them human
beings move like a mass of ants
clambering over each other to get away
from a gigantic ferocious lizard despite
the news broadcast declaring themselves
and their intentions to wipe out all of
humanity nobody on the ground would ever
be able to comprehend just why the
foundation Unleashed scp-682 and allowed
the heart to destroy reptile to
slaughter innocent civilians in drones
while they didn't know it or may not
have agreed Skye Renee Dane and Joe were
all lucky to have survived the initial
anomalous Onslaught Unleashed by a rogue
SCP Foundation it did little to ease the
pain of being displaced from their homes
forced to migrate across the country to
join camps of other survivors made
refugees by anomaly attacks and the
efforts of apathetic agents of the
foundation and of the four of them not
one could have predicted the shared fate
that awaited them during the months in
the wake of the foundation's opening
assault on mankind Renee and Skye had
mostly stuck together they had moved
further and further south managing to
stay safe neither one had thought about
their awkward date in months they were
just grateful to have someone they knew
to stick together with meanwhile Joe and
Dane were hopping from one refugee camp
to the next much in the same way moving
North and Eastward respectively after
deploying their first wave of anomalies
the SCP foundation's efforts had shifted
to primarily focusing on groups of
interest that could pose a threat to
their plans while organizations with
knowledge of the anomalous like the
global occult Coalition were among the
first in their crosshairs the civilian
population was left living in fear but
unscathed that is until the foundation
began targeting the refugee camps one of
their tactics was to unleash scp-22 241
a seven-year-old boy with reality
warping Powers into Survivor communities
to act as a living weapon destroying the
larger refugee camps it was the
increased frequency and ruthlessness of
the foundation's attacks on human
survivors that forced Skye Renee Dane
and Joe to a knowingly Converge on each
other camps for survivors started
getting smaller consisting of only a
handful of people in the hopes that this
would make it easier for them to avoid
detection by the foundation arriving and
hopping off the back of a Jeep with only
the clothes on their backs the four
strangers exchanged uncertain glances
they had been brought to an abandoned
dock the wreckage of an overturned cargo
ship laying on its side in the harbor
shipping containers were scattered all
around looking as if they had Spilled
Out of the boat and onto the dock the
driver of the Jeep hadn't told them
where to go from there instead he had
just driven off without so much as a
word the four of them looked around Dane
seemed particularly unnerved at being so
close to the water despite it having
been months since the Leviathan settled
back to sleep suddenly one of the
shipping containers burst open and a
broad flannel shirt wearing man stepped
out his face was buried beneath a thick
beard a shotgun resting against his
shoulder as he approached the group The
Man Stern Stony expression quickly
changed into a wide grin as he drovely
and unexpectedly pulled Dane into a hug
welcome my friends
the man roared with laughter Oh welcome
uh who are you Sky asked of course allow
me to introduce myself he responded
letting go of Dane who needed to catch
his breath after being squeezed so much
my name is jovianis for safety I watch
over this Camp the man announced okay
Camp Joe asked looking at the wreckage
the foundation has been getting more
zealous with targeting those of us that
are left joviannis explained gesturing
for the four to follow him as he walked
back towards the container so we had to
take a less conspicuous approach to
surviving splitting the camps up into
fewer people dispersing everyone around
a bit more end of of course he swung
open the door to the metal container
inside the cramped space there were two
bunks either side one above the other
making four in total along with a
sleeping bag on the floor standing
places the foundation one thing to look
jovianis continued we have to sleep in
here Renee Aston disbelief better for a
voice detection the camps protector
replied otherwise the next Camp along is
only 20 minutes away on foot over in a
warehouse if you'd rather go there but
be warned they have rats although it
came with a brief adjustment period the
group quickly acclimatized to living in
the abandoned dock each of them came to
appreciate joviannis's efforts to keep
them all fed with what few rations they
had the four of them started calling him
Big Joe referring to Joe as Lil Joe to
avoid confusion of the group Dane seemed
to have the hardest time adapting he was
something of a conspiracy theorist
anxiously talking about the other great
disasters throughout human history and
wondering if the foundation had been
responsible for them all Skye felt a
little sorry for him so they decided to
humor his theory that the eruption of
Mount Vesuvius in Pompeii was also the
SCP foundation's doing despite occurring
all the way back in 79 A.D through all
their various concerns about surviving
in this anomalous epileptic World Big
Joe seemed to have a talent for keeping
the group's spirits up whether it was by
recounting them all with folk stories or
turning bland food rations into more
flavorful meals he made the four of them
feel safe especially with his weapon
never far away that is until one evening
a glowing red streak shot through the
air not far from Camp catching
jovianus's immediate attention it was an
emergency flare set up by the
neighboring camp at the warehouse
something was wrong grabbing a shotgun
and urging Sky Dane Renee and Lil Joe to
stay put Big Joe left running off into
the growing dark of the night to try to
help the whole group stayed awake
waiting for their protector to return
the next hour feeling like an eternity
by the time he returned the sun had
fully set outside even by the low light
of their lamps inside the container it
was clear by his face that any and all
optimism had drained out of jovianis
there was nothing left of all there was
nothing left all of them were gone he
explained unable to believe what he had
seen or was this oil everywhere roasted
like an acid just burning through what
was left of them trying to regain some
semblance of composure he urged the
group to get some sleep reassuring them
that they would be safe for the rest of
the night not one of them realized just
how wrong they were or that they'd never
seen jovianis again after they fell
asleep Renee was the first to discover
he had gone missing screaming with panic
waking up sky and the two boys after
they had calmed down Skye tried to
rationalize what was going on they were
worried about Big Joe and the others but
he couldn't afford to lose their nerve
and potentially attract the attention of
a foundation kill Squad and it's the
foundation Dane babbled terrified they
found us they're closing in oh man relax
Sky replied all of you chill there are
other camps nearby maybe Big Joe went to
check on them too see if what had
happened to the warehouse group happened
anywhere
you don't think he would have told us
well Joe retorted seeming to be the
least concerned about joviannis's
whereabouts we were asleep it's not like
him to wake us up he knows we'd worry
Skye answered what if he's dead Renee
sobbed don't say that they replied she's
right though he left his shotgun right
here Joe interjected again whatever got
the warehouse group killed him it's
obvious at least I don't have to go by
that stupid nickname anymore what the
hell man Danielle you're joking at a
time like this what's wrong with you
there was an uncomfortably long pause
everyone in the container turned to look
at Joe leaning against one of the metal
walls with his arms folded the other
three were all thinking the same thing
although Dane was the first to say it
aloud you killed him didn't you don't be
ridiculous Joe chastised him backing
away slightly betraying his own little
hint of fear you and Renee are
hysterical you both need to calm down
before Joe could finish his sentence a
withered arm reached out of the wall and
grabbed his throat it looked like the
rotting decaying arm of a corpse
protruding out of a puddle of black
mucus that now seemed to be spreading
across the inner wall of the container
Renee screamed in horror as more of the
black substance Ooze from the arm
melting Away Joe as it held him
helplessly in its grip it was then that
a face peered through the oily patch
smeared on the wall the night nourished
Visage of
scp-106 the old man for a second Skye
thought about trying to help Joe they
could have pulled him free but it was
already too late the corrosion was
spreading it looked like it would melt
them too if they so much just touched it
Joe was gone the remaining three of them
burst out of the shipping container they
had called Home afraid for their lives
what the hell was that Dane screamed oh
man I knew it they've sent a monster
after us Skye barely paid him any mind
their attention grabbed by movement
nearby someone had started running the
second they had exited the shipping
crate they had been watching from a
distance
hey a stop this guy yelled about to run
after them die Renee's voice was
cracking under the weight of her Terror
turning around they saw it the old man
stood behind Renee it looked even more
grotesque under the low light provided
by several distant fires in the ruins of
cities the foundation had destroyed
given the Horizon a hellish glow
scp-106's withered lipless face bore his
rotting teeth locked in a skull-like
grin he'd give a sense he was gaining
some Twisted enjoyment out of what he
did next Renee had been frozen to the
spot sniffling in fear her legs rigid
and locked in place until the old man
claimed to hand over her shoulder then
she cried out in a blood-curdling shriek
of Agony more of the black ooze spilled
from his emaciated fingers dripping down
her front while Skye looked on in Terror
Renee had been the one person who had
been with them the entire time from the
moment the foundation Unleashed hell
every Camp they moved to Renee was in
the same one with them the pair of them
may have not been a couple but she had
been the only constant in this anomalous
apocalypse and now this Sinister SCP was
killing her fighting every urge to grab
Renee and pull her free Sky instead let
themselves be led Away by Dame choking
back tears they ran alongside him in the
direction of whoever had been watching
them the shadowy figure was just about
visible although definitely still close
enough to be heard in the dark there was
the sound of a fall accompanied by a
pained grunt indicating that whoever had
been watching the container had tripped
both Dane and Skye knew that this was
their chance together they lunged at the
figure before he had a chance to
scramble back to his feet with Dane
pinning The Observer down by his wrists
that was when the light of the burning
City on the horizon illuminated his face
he was the Jeep driver the one who had
dropped them at jovianus's Camp to begin
with the only other person apart from
Big Joe who knew where their Camp was
you Sky declared what were you doing
spying on us I have nothing to say to
you the man's man answer their question
Danielle and slapping the man in the
face although he didn't seem to react
what is this thing chasing us why did it
kill our friends you might as well tell
us Skye told him calmly after all once
that monster catches up we'll all be
dead you were watching expecting a
result right how to make sure none of us
made it not that there's anyone left for
us to tell if we did survive he's with
the foundation Dame catching on quickly
you had them send that corpse thing to
kill us man
scp-106 the undercover MTF agent
corrected and yeah it's here because we
sent it you all went underground hiding
in your little camps we had to look even
closer to find you all ungrateful all of
you ungrateful Sky exploded and raged
and offended at the idea anyone could
justify all the Death the foundation had
Unleashed on the world what do you
expect us to thank you for hunting your
fellow human beings to Extinction
dropping nightmare after Nightmare on us
and where were meant to be grateful for
that none of you understand what we're
trying to do the foundation agent
replied without a hint of remorse what
we're trying to do is bigger more
important than your mundane Little Lives
the only way we can save Humanity from
It Is by wiping you out before either
sky or Dane could ask what it was a
gloopy oily smear appeared on the ground
clawing his way out of it the old man
reached for the MTF operative
disintegrating him like he had done
before but the agent barely reacted
didn't cry out like Renee or Joe had he
was still even as he was being melted by
the slimy black secretion of
scp-106 it was as if the man couldn't
feel the pain of what was happening to
him as he died a splatter of the same
corrosive mucus spread onto Dane's
sleeve freaking out as it began burning
through his jacket he desperately tried
to wipe it off only to smear it
spreading the dissolving substance
further and crying out as he felt it
eating into the palms of his hands
scp-106 climbed out of its oily puddle
dropping the disintegrating MTF agent he
disappeared into the corrosive pool
Vanishing from sight like he'd fallen
into a ditch Skye backed away their eyes
locked with the sunken stare of the old
man feeling their legs begin to freeze
in fear just like Renee's gun Dane raft
laying at scp-106's feet slowly
succumbing to the same fate that I'd
befallen the others big big Joe's gun he
rasped again with the last of his
strength he used his arm to grab the old
man's ankle howling in pain as more of
the black substance oozed from the
monster's wrinkled flesh Sky turned and
raced back towards the shipping
container hardly daring to look over
their shoulder every movement every tiny
shift of Shadow they detected in the
corner of their eye filled their mind
with the images of the old man bearing
down on them wearing that sadistic
skeletal grin Sky pulled the heavy metal
door open using all their strength to
get back inside their arms were numbed
trembling so much with Terror that it
was like they weren't attached properly
they fumbled about in the dark their
fingers brushing up against the weapon
resting in the corner where jovianis had
left it pulling on the pump Sky turned
the gun raised knowing that the old man
was right behind them and pulled the
trigger it gave a redundant click it was
empty no ammunition the gun had been
just for show
scp-106 reached for the weapon and
pulled it from Skye's hands the metal of
it slowly melting as it was coated in
the tar-like corrosive substance
recoiling their hands from it Skye went
to dash for the door only to feel the
old man's bony burning fingers hook into
their back and drag them towards the
greasy black stain he was leaning out of
pulling them into his domain this world
had been a living nightmare since the
foundation had revealed itself and
Unleashed an anomalous apocalypse upon
Humanity but scp-106's
pocket Dimension might just have been
worse now go and check out scp-5000 the
full story compilation and scp-106
Containment Breach if you'd like a
little more of this particular flavor of
existential nightmare